[Music]
I need don't know my mind BL some all
the
time want to lose a Drifter that's
me you can travel
Force rambler's heart go
WR baby you don't know my mind today
[Music]
hey how's it going Devon here again with
country guitar
online.com we've got an awesome lesson
today we're going to go over how to play
honey you don't know my mind it's an old
country and Bluegrass song written by
Jimmy Skinner a long time ago and it's
been redone a couple different times by
Jimmy Martin and by Tony Rice both of
them have awesome versions of this song
also that's say Ty typically this song
is done with Capo on the second fret but
today we're going to do it standard open
tuning just to keep it easy and so we
can talk about fret numbers a little
easier and uh we're in the key of G for
this song and we're first going to go
over all the rhythm guitar part going to
break down the chord progression that
you need there are two chord
progressions and we will have a PDF of
the chords and the lyrics that you can
download here at country guitar online
if you're watching this on YouTube there
should be a link below this YouTube
video that will it'll take you straight
over to the site here where you can
download all the stuff uh after the
Rhythm we will get into these awesome
instrumental breaks and this is my
favorite part about this song is These
instrumental breaks we'll have three
versions that I put together we have a
beginner version and then we'll have an
intermediate and then we'll have a
slightly more advanced version of this
instrumental
break anyways let's get to it let's zoom
in and start going over the rhythm
guitar part first and then we'll break
down these instrumental
braks there's only two main chord
progressions that you need to play this
entire song We're first going to go over
the instrumental break chord progression
and this instrumental breake progression
is the same progression that you will
play for the intro as well no difference
and we're just going to go over the
chords now and we'll get into the
strumming pattern stuff
later but let me play through this one
time so you can hear it and then I'll
explain a little bit what I'm going to
do is just all downstroke
and each of those letters that you see
here in this chart that's going to be
one counts worth so that first look at
that first line that first measure those
Four G's it's going to sound like
this you
know okay so let me play through
it 1 2 3 4 g g g g g g c c
d d d d g g g repeat it g g g g g g c c
g d d d g g d g and want an extra
measure of G right at the end
[Music]
here if you look at those two lines
they're are the exact same there's no
difference except for on that second
line there's that extra measure of G
added on to the end and all that extra
measure does is Just Lead You In It kind
of builds up into the verse when you
start the
singing so
um so yeah that's pretty much all
there's to with the instrumental break
nine measures Worth right there nine
measures in total now looking at this
verse here it's a little bit strange how
I've got this written out you'll see
that first measure it's got six counts
of g in it which really one measure is
just going to have four counts but I
wrote it out like this because once you
start singing I think it makes a little
more sense to look at it this way and
let me play through it you can hear it
and then I'll explain how this stuff
fits together so here we
go honey you don't
my
mind lome all the
[Music]
time
B Drifter that's
me repeat
[Music]
it
d c c c c d d d d
g g g
g that's it that's the verse and both of
those lines they are the exact
same so those extra two counts it's it's
just broken these core changes are
broken up a little strange but those
extra two counts if you take those two
counts from the first line and then you
add them to the extra two counts on the
second line in total you get four extra
counts there which create which equals
one complete measures worth so at the
end of the day this whole verse chord
progression is still nine measures long
just like the instrumental break that
was nine measures long this verse one
verse progression is nine measures long
also just way the chords are the chord
changes happen are a little
strange kind of just got to play through
it a little bit and get familiar with
this progression and sing it now I
always get confused once I start
switching back and forth between these
progressions because I have the tendency
you know those instrumental break
progressions that c chord it's only held
out for two counts but then when you
switch to the verse the C chord is held
out for four counts it just throws me
off every time almost but um anyways
this progression will be written out
right below this video here at country
guitar online you can check this out
later refer back to it if you need to
but at this point those are the chord
progressions let's get into the
strumming pattern a little bit and break
down basic pattern you can use and then
we'll add a little bit extra to it to
make it more
complicated when I strum this song the
main strumming pattern that I use for
this entire song is this one is if yall
have seen previous videos in this series
you'll already be familiar with this
strumming pattern but it's this basic
boom chick pattern boom chick boom chick
boom boom chick boom chick where the
boom that's just a pick of the
individual bass note and then the the
chick is a down strum on the skinnier
strings so it's all down down Strokes
here there's a down pick and then a down
strum just over and over again down down
pick down pick down pick down pick
down boom chick boom chick so that's it
and once we start adding more to this
strumming you still want to in EMP ize
that pick and the strum you know but
we'll add in some accent strums in
between all that to make it sound more
complicated but you
still you want it to sound like you're
playing the boom chick pattern you want
that to be the dominant strumming
pattern basically
[Music]
now let's go through these three
different instrumental breaks we got we
got the beginner version then the
intermediate then the advanced and what
you can do is take one of these
instrumental brakes and play it as the
intro of the song as well sounds pretty
good so first we're going over the
beginner version it's going to sound a
little bit like
[Music]
this so always we got going on in that
beginner version basically is this main
boom chick Rhythm pattern boom chick
boom chick boom chick boom chick like
that but now we're just going to add in
these melodic Baseline fills right into
that
[Music]
pattern so if you take that that
Baseline Melody right there mix it into
the boomshake pattern sounds pretty cool
so that's the whole main idea for this
this beginner instrumental
Break um as you learn all these Baseline
fills also keep in mind that these notes
of the fills are straight out of the G
Major scale fifth position the one that
we've been studying a ton of Prior
lessons in this series fifth position G
Major scale this one right
here if you haven't seen those videos
prior to this one of the series go check
those out this will make a lot more
sense but if you can visualize the scale
if you haven't memorized already um
visualize it as you're learning the
fills so then you'll really be able to
understand where these notes are coming
from and you'll be able to apply them a
lot easier to jam type of situations and
create your own fill Rifts just right on
the
spot so anyways let's zoom in and let's
start going through this beginner uh
instrumental break and then we'll go
over the intermediate version here in
one
second all right here are the first two
measures of the beginner instrumental
[Music]
break that's it first two measures so
you see there let's look at that first
measure it's all G
chord it's like that we're doing down
pics and down strums this whole time you
can see those down pick the pick
Direction triangles right below the
teture
and this first measure you know since
it's all G chord I leave my left ring
finger and my left pinky planted down
the whole time throughout this whole
measure as if I was playing a G
chord but then I'm lifting up my left
pointer and my left middle finger
throughout this thing to pick up those
Baseline fill
wrists just like that
[Music]
that's the first
measure then it moves into the second
measure here still playing the G
chord but then it walks up the scale to
the
C and you hear a lot of people say walk
up and walk down basically all that
means is you're going to play if you're
walking up you're going to play the
notes up the scale and that's exactly
what we did right there in the second
measure g a b
C and that's straight from that fifth
position G Major
scale you know g a b c
[Music]
l
a
[Music]